I love chicken tenders so much the
American chicken tenders are like next
level it is they're so good every we had
a we had like chicken tenders at the
Nashville hot chicken places I can't
remember which one it was also the one
that like Charlie got us in Tampa as
well yeah
it's dude I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm about
to go off but I'm about to go chicken
tenders are so [ __ ] good dude
American I I have I have a message for
Americans okay uh because I understand
now why these two think all chicken
taste the same why is that because every
time you [ __ ] eat chicken you only
eat chicken dendies I'm like there is
more to chicken Americans than [ __ ]
chicken tenders so [ __ ] tired of
chicken tenders I'm like there is you
guys don't seem to eat anything like
every time we got like a recommendation
for a chicken George you know people
like yo like Raising Canes is like so
much better and some people like yo
Chick-fil-A so much better I'm like it's
all you're just eating chicken tendons
they don't do 10. it's either ten
dollars nuggets I'm like I'm like it's a
contend he's a God too man
I I could I could eat chicken tendys
every single day oh every single best so
far
those sauces they had bro not stupid it
just it just like annoyed me to no ends
like every time we'd go to a chicken
place what are we having chicken tendies
I'm like do you not have wings do you
not have the thighs do you not have the
[ __ ] like you don't have the legs
it's just like there's so much to a
chicken and every time it was like they
were like yo Raising Cane's God's here
this is so much better than the other
place and I'm like it's all the [ __ ]
same because all you're really judging
is the sauce you're not even judging the
[ __ ] chicken all the chicken quality
was good it was good quality it was it's
like you know I I think like most of the
most of the chicken places we went to
the chicken quality was kind of the same
so the only thing you kind of the only
thing you were kind of judging is like
the sauce right the chicken called
quality at that at that local Tampa one
that Charlie got us was like the chicken
itself tasted so much it was so it was
like the perfect moistness it wasn't too
much batter but there was a shitload of
chicken and the sauce oh but I heard you
like Hershey's chocolate is this true no
oh Cindy said you love Hershey's ah
geez is or is love a strong word two
days ago two days ago yeah
I think I understand why though
fundamentally why God was so sick of
chicken tandies because he doesn't eat
sauce
is like what the [ __ ] what are you doing
don't even bother but like there's like
this there's so much to chicken like the
okay here's the thing why I don't like
chicken tendies okay or no it's not like
I don't like it but like I would prefer
to have other types of chicken because
you remove like one of the best part of
the chicken in my mind which is the skin
because you just like you you get rid of
the skin no and there's like there's
crispiness dude the crispiness the
crispy batter is where it's at bro oh
no [ __ ]
the batteries
the batter is good but the batter with
like the skin Cooks well that's why
that's why you know when when you go to
KFC and you have like anything but
chicken Denny's the best part is the
[ __ ] skin I will say uh I'm sorry
yeah and like there is when when we had
chicken and waffles and you guys ordered
chicken breasts with your waffles that
like triggered me to no end I I did that
to trigger you on purpose that was like
there was like a list of like you that
the only time where these boys had a
choice of which part of the chicken they
would prefer to have with this with
their meal they could have ordered
breasts they could have ordered Wings
they could have ordered thighs
um and they ordered like two breasts
to be fair I I I chose I chose a breast
and a thigh and I will say the thigh was
definitely better in that instance
chicken tend these is on another level
how clean breast tastes yeah compared
thigh yeah
um [ __ ] there was something else I just
forgot I'm an idiot um something sauce
sauce thing about the sauces [ __ ] I
forgot something about chicken something
about chicken you know what you know
what I think America unequivocally does
not that anywhere else what chicken
wings straight up chicken wings are like
ginormous yeah they're they're right I
don't know how the [ __ ] they get clearly
something is going wrong the chicken
wings are like that in the U.S but I I'm
not complaining because they're huge
they're [ __ ] those chickens it's so
much meat on the chicken wing it's
insane they're on their creator Clash
diet
I I disagree
where do you think does chicken wings
better than the US uh Korea
to me like to me like wouldn't that just
be the saucer yeah wouldn't that just be
the sauce no no no it's it's not the
sauce right it's like they like the Yum
Yum Chicken it's it's like you know it
can be a uh mixture between like the
meat to skin ratio the meat so like like
a batter ratio you know I feel like the
chicken wings in uh America there's like
too much meat that it [ __ ] up with the
ratio of like the marinade right I'm I'm
I I love I love Korean fried wings so
much but God damn do those American
Wings go hard like they go so much
harder I I'd say like what I think
America does better than anywhere else
in the world is barbecue I was like I
will give American barbecue as the best
barbecue in the world I think America
does the best I mean this I really want
to try like uh Caribbean barbecue and
that kind of that kind of area yeah
because I know
I've had like that uh the Cuban barbecue
oh it wasn't really barbecue but it was
like kind of barbecue-esque Cuban food
in um in Orlando it was like the Cuban
restaurant we went to in Miami there was
just like nothing but meat and that's
pretty good that place was that place
was pretty crazy yeah I wouldn't say
it's Bobby but it's like barbecue-esque
in terms of like what's that no bro
South Korea has good Wings they have
they have the I'm sure North Korea has
good wings too if they have any there's
definitely no meat on those bones though
I said that but what are you talking
about don't get me wrong you've been
America you've been in America no you're
like more better more food equals better
I I order from I obviously it's in Japan
but a lot of these like a lot of them
are like Korean chains that are in Japan
and I ordered a bunch dude they're just
too flimsy bro there's no there's no
meat on the bone it's just all skin I I
think the one thing I like about a lot
of like American chicken wing is that
like a lot of the places at least the
ones we went it's not fried chicken for
starters but like the source is like
separate to the wing right so you can
like dip as much more as little sauce as
you want whereas the Yum Yum Ranch but
like the Yum Yum she doesn't like souls
for example it depends on the sauce
okay okay
I don't like Crown God you're right
that's why I don't belong in America
Midwestern girl how could you not like
wrench is it even possible to not like
Ranch but I'm just like is there more
sauce than just Ranch because I'm like
you don't need anything I mean to me I'm
I'm not saying there's so much more
variety in like other countries it's all
about one [ __ ] sauce okay let's go
let's go through it all then honey
mustard yeah
yes okay what else what what other
condiments can you eat with a chicken
wing what other condiments can you eat
with a chicken wing oh you don't like
barbecue I actually do I mean I
literally just said American barbecue I
think barbecue works better with like
beef and pork rather than chicken uh
like I said I prefer like there's uh
there's a lot of like Thai chicken wings
as well with like this very it's a very
sour spicy sauce right
um I like the Korean chicken wings as
well with like a little bit of sweet I
like spicy stuff buffalo sauce I do love
buffalo the buffalo wings are the goat I
[ __ ] that's that's the best I just don't
want them to drench it too much yeah
that's what I don't like about buffalo
sauce it's like when it's sometimes it's
just too I go too hot I don't get it
because you drench it in the sauce in
the ranch anyway what's the difference
the ranch you need to drench it the rent
there because Ranch is great because
rice is amazing I could drink red it's
so good because you drink sauce you can
eat the buffalo sauce and then you want
to mix it up you're like dip it in some
ranch yeah you can do Buffalo and Ranch
mixture bomb Oh I'm like I'm like so
what I'm so what I'm understanding here
what I'm understanding
is that you guys just really [ __ ]
like Ranch no but the wings are amazing
the wings are even without the wrench
are way better than anything yeah you
get like because I'm actually eating
meat yeah whereas like in I disagree
I said I said I think there is like I've
got what was like the biggest wins you
want in America because I'm I'm thinking
about the wings I get in the [ __ ]
Midwest and in in the midwest they are
[ __ ] obese
yeah they're huge These Wings Are
massive yeah that's why it's good I
think I'm like I'm like I I there is
like to me like well you guys you guys
eat chicken breasts right so okay I'm
just I'm just gonna realize like you
[ __ ] love the white meat you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] love that [ __ ] that's what I
love chicken I like a mixture between
like you know the the skin as well I
like a mixture between having the
marinade on it it's not always about
fried sometimes you grill it as well
that's why I love like the massive
chicken wings though because there's so
much meat on one chicken wing with one
chicken wing you can like mix and
matches around being like all right
first bite gonna put some ranchers
and it's just so good dude because okay
do you do you dip your chicken with
Wings in the sauce sometimes sometimes
yeah because to me chicken wings chicken
wings are like
you know you've chickened yeah
pre-marinated chicken you dip in the
sauce is [ __ ] chicken tendies it's
nuts because there's no bugs no there's
no bones right I you know the reason I
like Bones the one with the bone yeah
the one with the bone like the
drumsticks you can dip it in the sauce
oh you're talking about are you talking
about drumsticks I've thought you're
talking about wings easy wings as well
you get a wings as well yeah but like if
you can't get it in the container then
you get the container like pour it on
top just like your [ __ ] fight into it
that's just like and it's good [ __ ]
that's not I thought that was like the
one advantage of having boneless chicken
which is that you can just it's just
yeah why do you think we love boneless
chicken because of the convenience I can
eat everything but if the wing is there
then I'm gonna be like well if there's
only Wings here then I'm obviously gonna
eat it because I like wings as well but
it's a little bit inconvenient for me to
have to grab the sauce and pour it on
top that's it and I'm just like the the
[ __ ] advantage of wings is that
normally it's early candies I can just
get straight into that [ __ ] it's like
perfectly shaped to fit the container
normally the advantage of wings is that
it just tastes good by itself it's
already marinated or it's already got
sauce you don't have to dip it in yeah I
like it sometimes with it with and
without it's just a different flavor you
want to mix it up yeah you want to mix
it up it's clown take on one of what I'm
what I'm like discovering right now is
that these two just doesn't they don't
care about the taste of the chicken it's
all about the taste of the sauce you
know that's that's what do you mean no
one eats chicken wings with no sauce or
dry rub or anything that's psychotic are
you Dr you there's dry rubs yeah no no
you're not and you know literally the
[ __ ] Wings we had in the office from
like that male in cook they were dry
rubs no I know I like that yeah I'm not
arguing against them sometimes you want
to put more sauce on it yeah why is it
so hard to comprehend sometimes I wanna
I I like the option of one additional
shoes if I want extra sauce or not
sometimes you know I'm in the mood where
I'm like I don't need the extra sauce
because it already tastes good enough
sometimes I want a little more yeah but
like what I'm what I'm trying to say is
what I think good wings are well I think
good chicken is is that it should taste
good you know by itself if you are
putting too much sauce in it then you're
not really judging the chicken you're
judging the sauce which is like which is
like my biggest pet peeve with a lot of
like chicken places
because the chicken wing sucks no amount
of sauce is Gonna Save it yeah I'm not
gonna eat it
I think we like the taste of the chicken
we just like it also it can be enhanced
yeah I like I already like the taste of
the chicken but with the sauce it's like
an added bonus yeah yeah but if the
chicken wing sucks no amount of ranch is
going to save that [ __ ] I don't know man
with the amount of ranch I see Americans
put on their chicken wings I it just
seems like putting a [ __ ] ton of ranch
is not a choice it's the default unless
that's one and you know what I'm glad
it's not even about how good the wings
are it's about how much sauce you put on
it and I'm just like multiple times
throughout the tour where all I had to
say was Ranch and I got an entire crowd
chanter everyone loves Ranch everyone
loves Ranch it's [ __ ] awesome it's
great I don't like well luckily you're
not everybody
thankfully you're the minority